I am not of the opinion that sex is
biological sex is all that matters and
gender expression does not matter quite
the opposite I think that man is not a
purely biological or physical being I
think that man is a hylomorphic being a
combination of Body Soul and Spirit and
I think that the body is a symbol of our
soul that the soul is the substantial
form of the body now the transgender
argument when it is made in the very
best way it can possibly be made I think
uses this kind of language and that
gender expression or gender identity is
really just a modern term to refer to
the soul the immaterial metaphysical
Soul now the problem with transgenderism
is it suggests that the soul in the body
can be in opposition to one another
which is not true the soul and the body
are united here on Earth they're
inextricable because as I mentioned the
soul is the form of the body and so I
totally Grant the gender expression is
extraordinarily complex